[Music]
so in brick beating news Oh No what
beating brick oh no oh god beat before
is this what I think it is submitted by
a tide sewer trout interesting
oh wait that happened again corn I sewer
trout oh I did yeah who is that that
what he's not one of those things when
you say really fast corner so we thought
the last time too but we couldn't find
anything it was part of a article was it
no it was long it was a submitter Oh was
that I leave in the comments below what
the [ __ ] is a corn I'd sewer trout I
said oh it's one of them literally what
he said is what I said last probably
some sex position can you just google it
yeah [ __ ] tell me corn I'd sewer
trout it's probably a real fish oh you
know what it is it's [ __ ] Dookie is
it [ __ ] horn I'd Brown sewer trash
Dookie long piece of Duty's bean corn in
it yeah but it's called brown trout is
that like a redneck term Hornets who
trap
sounds like it yeah yeah so a 91 year
old man was beaten with a brick while
going for a walk on the 4th of July what
reason for no [ __ ] reason was it a
crazy homeless la man no it was a
freakin American woman oh that's not
real we should do it though because she
said 4th of July [ __ ] okay well it's
not for no okay so this is it's not for
independence they're not said like go
back to your country type of [ __ ]
because she's bored she said go back to
Mexico oh man I know is she crazy
obviously obviously okay so this story
here it takes place do you guys know
where Willowbrook is always right by
confidence yeah it's near Compton you're
Lynwood so here in LA it sounds like a
really nice place isn't it yes it was my
cockatiel in with another
Rodolfo Rodriguez 91 years old he was
taking his afternoon walk after you know
he ate and so he was walking around the
neighborhood as he always does every day
walking off as in love me yeah all of a
sudden he came across this black woman
with her four-year-old or we believe
she's four years old his little girl
very unsuspecting yeah and so like
apparently this woman says like she was
saying that he bumped into the little
girl
we're doleful bummed into the little
girl but he says he didn't and then so I
don't know exactly what happened the
point is she all of a sudden just starts
beating his ass a brick somehow gets
involved in this beating calls out to
these or other men that were nearby and
she's telling them hey you're trying to
kidnap my little girl or like oh like
he's trying to do something to my little
girl so then these four dudes come over
and start beating his ass to a 90
something you're all gone oh no he's
about to turn 92 in September people
can't tell he's [ __ ] 91 he can't move
that's when this witness she saw this go
down from her car and this so she
started recording but then when she
tried to intervene as likely to ends up
throwing the brick at her so then she's
like what the [ __ ] so there's I'm gonna
show you a video clip of when this
woman's a video clip Rodolfo
so warning he's really buddy she doesn't
know how to record they went around the
corner that's again what happened and he
looks good for anyone though he does you
know what a 91 girl look like that he's
really this is the one another she's big
involved and then this little girl she
was beating this man in front of this
little girl she even like a linebacker
what the [ __ ] she looks very strong
looks very much what is she oh good he's
91 that's gonna take him three years to
heal because they got poor circulation
you do word of [ __ ] did you find that
pretty yeah did she just wedge it out of
the wall like everything's broken over
there
why does arm open like Jesus Christ [ __ ]
we'll go fund me for Adolfo which
they've clearly very much surpassed holy
[ __ ] forty-four thousand dollars medical
expenses dude the hospital bills are
expensive man
dang I I wish I like saw the whole thing
go down you know like what the hell
there's just a lot that clip was what
was posted to Facebook I wasn't able to
find the clip of where they saw this
woman but I don't know but yeah this
just went viral cuz he was going for a
walk yeah he's just going for a walk to
ghetto I mean we part lives there no he
was actually visiting his family from
Mexico but he visits twice a year so
like he's familiar with that slam I
should have let him walk around
yeah that's pretty crazy cuz I can kind
of see it were like if this lady is kind
of nuts and in her mind she sees it as
this dude is a threat to her baby then
it's like her mommy her mommy defense
system comes in like I got killed his
mother [ __ ] yeah but it doesn't matter
it's like once that [ __ ] I got to
protect chicks in I think the [ __ ]
life or death comes in you know yeah but
it had to be tied in with some crazy
yeah that's at some point before the
brick happens you realize you want yeah
if you're if you're a saint yeah yeah
before you callin for other people yeah
exactly that's what I mean by in their
world like in that crazies world they're
justifying it like they gotta protect no
and I'm [ __ ] whatever means like
gotta protect the baby did she get a car
as of right now they are still looking
for this woman and those three to four
other suspects but no one's gonna rat in
the hood though mm-hmm
the woman who posted this video they're
saying that they kind of have an idea
who they are but that they just want the
police to find them see cousin nothing
around they're not gonna rap yeah so
apparently the grandpa he suffered a
broken jaw broken cheek bones broken two
broken ribs
bruises all over his face back and
abdomen and he spent five or six hours
in the hospital and now he's recovering
he says that he's in a lot of pain look
yeah holy he can't walk anymore
Oh at least not for now yeah that's one
of those like how the [ __ ] can you see
that coming you know you're just walking
around
and you get accused of some [ __ ] and
then you get jumped I don't know if I
was 91 I think I would just walk her out
with a [ __ ] rifle for no reason
well I just have a cane with the [ __ ]
sword editor's yeah I like a gun cane
nah man I can't even swing anything
anymore my swings gonna be like this
these probably healthier than you think
though if he's with that beaten and
didn't yeah well that'd be worse Dana
it's like no miracle he didn't die on
the spot yeah damn he's got that strong
Mexican farmer gene well yeah he did say
like you know he's never done anything
wrong to anyone even like in the fields
or something like I don't know I forgot
what the context was but yeah well you
said that he was a farmer cuz a lot of I
feel like a lot of farmers get they stay
strong
till a old age if they're like working
outside and [ __ ] they're just moving
something here it isn't in a life
working in the fields with cattle and
corn that's where I read that yeah they
stay strong you've never been hurt like
this before
damn I saw my grandma fall down once and
she had a bruise for the whole year for
real yep just from one fall
yeah that's I'm saying that like falling
off the bed and elderly breaking their
hips and says I'd like the worst thing
that could happen to them because it's
really hard for them to recover from
that I saw my grandpa fall too but it
was really funny me too mommy to beat I
was the kid and I'm just playing in the
hallway of the house and I just hear it
and I walk over there and my ground that
she was cooking and she slipped somehow
so she fell down she's on her husband
she's holding that too like kitchen
utensil I started I know I just look
[ __ ] hilarious eyeshadow apron on it
she's like this my mom comes starts
beating the [ __ ] out of me before that
I didn't laugh because my grandpa fell I
laugh because my grandpa is such an
[ __ ] about it like he was so defined
because I could Sacramento gets cold in
the winter and so outside we got this
like wood and deck thing but I told that
I do not to go out Tom straight up don't
go out don't go out don't go out he's I
call me stupid and dumb and I was like
oh my god I just see through the screen
though I can't hear anything cuz it's a
closed screen door he's walking out
there and you see what you get you
[ __ ] alright I come back inside the
house okay of course he was fine he just
had a long Bruce ya bruise on his butt
for a bit he's okay
yeah breaking him it's a long time yeah
he lived up to 98 damn 92 years from 100
dude and he died on purpose - I know he
did why we had to put him into a home at
that point because he was too old and we
couldn't give him the care that he
needed it was like I then I'll kill
myself
he just died he died the next day he's
like no I
he said he died I was like damn dude
that's tight he died like this choking
himself out oh good he died like this
poor my grandson I love them to rest in
peace grandpa you piece of [ __ ] hell of
you man I can't wait til I get that
delusional you're already there I'm not
there yet I got a beat in it you know I
mean like I got a [ __ ] wake up one
day and there's a purple giraffe in my
bed chillin and there's a [ __ ] happy
mushroom that's [ __ ] dancing and
saying hi grandpa Joe that's when I know
I made it that's the mention I'm trying
to get into man I'm trying to get into
that DMT level but in reality
have you tried no cuz it scares the [ __ ]
out of me
[Music]